The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEFF GORE: Today, what we want
to do is focus more explicitly
on bacterial chemotaxis.
Of course, a
discussion that we had
on Thursday about "Life
at Low Reynolds Numbers"
is certainly very
relevant to this question
of how bacteria are
maybe able to find food
or what constraints
they're faced in trying
to solve this problem.
Today, we're going to
discuss in more depth
this idea of the biased random
walk that runs and tumbles
that we talked about on
Thursday, that allow bacteria
to swim towards attractants
and away from repellents.
But in particular,
there's something
that is rather subtle about the
particular biased random walk
that bacteria implement.
Now, the way that you
might kind of naively
imagine that this
thing would work
is that you would just have
this tumbling frequency be
a function of the concentration
of the attractant, for example.
And that indeed would allow
you to swim or to execute
a biased random walk
towards, say, food sources,
towards attractants,
but it would not
be effective over a very
wide range of concentrations.
However, if you experimentally
ask, how well can bacteria
swim towards
attractants, it turns out
they can respond over
five orders of magnitude
of concentration of these
attractants, which is really
quite incredible, if you think
about the engineering challenge
that these little one-micron
cells are able to overcome.
And the basic way that
they do this is they
implement what's essentially
equivalent to integral feedback
in the context of engineering,
where it turns out
that the steady-state tumbling
frequency, so the frequency
of which they'd
execute one of these
tumbles that randomizes their
motion, that displays what's
known as perfect adaptation.
It's not a function of the
concentration of-- if you have
a constant concentration
of an attractant,
then it's not a
function of that.
Of course, changes in
concentrations it responds to,
but somehow, E. coli and
many other microorganisms
are able to implement this
very clever thing where
the steady-state frequency
of tumbling, of changing
direction, is somehow
not a function
of the overall
attractant concentration.
Now, that's already an
interesting, I think,
phenomenon.
And in some ways,
you can think of it
as some kind of
robustness, because there
is some way in which this
tumbling frequency is
robust against constant changes
in the level of attractants.
And it's that
aspect, I think, that
makes this example both
rather subtle but also
quite confusing, because
it's the phenomenon
of perfect adaptation
that already
has some aspects of
robustness, but it's
this phenomenon of
perfect adaptation
that is robust against changes
in concentrations of proteins,
for example, the concentration
of the protein [? key ?]
R that we're going
to talk about.
So I think that this
is in some ways maybe
the prettiest
example that we have
of this principle
of robustness, but I
think it's also in
some ways the most
tricky to wrap your head around,
because it's sort of robustness
of a robustness in some ways.
All right.
So our goal for today is
going to be to make sure
that we understand the challenge
that E. coli are facing
and then to try to understand
the genetic circuit
that they use in order to
overcome this challenge.
So what I'm going to do for
the next hour and 15 minutes
is we're going to leave
this network up on the board
so that any time that
you're confused about what
is R, B, Z, Y, so
forth, you can kind of
look up here and remind
yourself what this thing is.
But hopefully, the
reading from last night
will help you in
following what's going on.
There are a fair number of
letters, I will admit it.
So first, I just
want to make sure
that we're all
kind of remembering
the basic phenomenon
that we're trying
to study, which is this idea of
consecutive runs and tumbles.
So this random walk is really
composed of what you might call
or what we do call runs,
where the bacteria goes sort
of straight and
then tumbles, which
they randomize their motion.
So this is runs and tumbles,
where bacteria, they
go semi-straight for of order
a second-- order one second--
and this is the run.
Then, they have
this tumbling that
might last about one second,
so a 0.1 second tumble,
over which the motion is
sort of random in this axis
of the orientation.
And then, they kind of
go in a new direction
and then tumble again and then
new direction and so forth.
So it's runs
followed by tumbles.
Now, the thing that
changes depending
on whether the cells
are sensing that they're
moving up or down, say,
an attractant gradient
is the frequency of
those tumbles, i.e.
how long are the runs?
I said that they're
around one second,
but this will vary depending
upon whether bacteria
sense that things
are getting better
or things are getting worse.
Can somebody remind us how
the bacteria actually execute
one of these tumble motions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: They have this other
motors-- they have mini-motors
in their flagella
and they usually
all spin one way, which I
think is counterclockwise.
JEFF GORE: That's right.
I always have trouble--
so the runs are indeed
when these things are
rotating counterclockwise.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And one of them can
decide to switch
and start turning clockwise.
And what it does, it just
sort of-- I don't know.
I just imagine it throws
the whole motor off.
JEFF GORE: Exactly.
And the flagella in the context
of-- so we have our E. coli.
The velocity is of order,
say, 30 microns per second.
Now, they have these
flagella that are actually
distributed-- the motors
are actually distributed
across the entire cell.
So it's not just on the back.
But then, these individual
filaments kind of
come together towards
the back and then
they have this corkscrew shape.
When these things
are all rotating
in the counterclockwise
direction,
that corresponds to a run,
when there's directed motion.
But then if one of
them goes clockwise,
the bundle falls apart.
And indeed, there are some
very nice movies online
where you can see that when
they're going clockwise,
you see that the flagella are
kind of doing crazy things
and that causes this
thing to kind of tumble
in a random orientation.
So it randomizes its direction.
Now, one thing that
we did not talk
about in the context of this
low Reynolds number motion
was the question of
how hard you would
have to pull in
order to get a cell
to go 30 microns per second.
Now, remember, we're in the
low Reynolds number regime,
where the force
you have to apply
is in general proportional
to this velocity.
And this thing is very
much not a sphere,
but if it were a sphere, for
a sphere, the proportionality
constant is this 6 pi eta
av, where a here is again
the radius.
Now, regardless of
the precise shape,
you'll always get for the low
Reynolds regime something that
looks vaguely like this, where
this is going to the longest
linear dimension and this here
depends on the precise geometry
of the object.
And so just-- it's
useful to try to get
a sense of order of magnitude.
How large are these forces
that we're talking about?
In particular,
how hard would you
have to pull a cell
in order to get
it to go 30 microns per second?
Now, of course then,
there's a question.
What's roughly the scale that
we should be thinking about?
Right now, a newton is the scale
that's for macroscopic objects.
So you'd say, OK, probably
not going to be up that large.
Then, on the other
scale, we can think
about the forces that
can be applied or exerted
by individual molecular motors.
Has anybody studied this at all?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Right,
order of picanewtons.
So force for a
molecular motor is going
to be of order picanewtons.
Now, there's a
simple way to kind of
get at why this might actually
be, because what is it
that powers many of
these molecular motors?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Yeah, so
it's often-- you're
thinking of maybe the motors
that operate in a membrane.
And then, there might
be some difference
in a gradient, so a
difference in concentration
across that membrane
and that can actually
power, for example, rotation.
We're going to talk
a little bit more
about this in the context
of the flagella motor,
because this is one of only
a few known rotary motors.
I'm just going to write this
down so that I don't forget
to say something about it.
But in this case--
AUDIENCE: ATP?
JEFF GORE: ATP, right?
So in many cases, what
happens is that you have,
for example, kinesin or myosin.
These are motors that walk along
some track and in many cases,
each step corresponds to a
single ATP being hydrolyzed.
And so given that,
there's some maximal force
that you can imagine
such a motor applying.
So for example-- and what
might it depend upon?
AUDIENCE: The energy of
ATP hydrolysis [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Ah, very good.
So we have delta G for say, ATP.
And there's going to be
a length scale, right?
And what's going to
be the relevant length
scale in the case of, for
example, a motor like kinesin?
AUDIENCE: The flagella, I guess?
JEFF GORE: Well, kinesin is
not walking along the flagella,
but in this case, kinesin is
walking along microtubules,
for example.
So you're right that
we need a length scale,
because this is going to have
some units of say, picanewton
nanometers-- oops,
that's an Nm--
and we want to get a picanewton
so we're going to need a length
scale to divide by, right?
AUDIENCE: So how long
you move each time?
JEFF GORE: That's right.
It's kind of the distance that
this thing's moving, right?
So indeed, what happens
in the case of kinesin
is that they take steps
with what are called "heads"
but we can think of them
as "feet" if we want.
So each step is in this
case eight nanometers.
For example, delta L for kinesin
is equal to eight nanometers.
You don't need to know
this, but just it's
useful to have some
sense of scale.
Now, of course,
delta G of ATP, this
depends upon the concentrations
of the reactants,
of the products, and so forth.
But this thing might be of
order 100 picanewton nanometers.
Now, depending on
conditions, maybe it's
70, but of order here.
And indeed, what
this tells us is
that just based on what
we've said right now, even
without building any fancy
microscopes to measure
how much force these
things can apply,
you can see that the maximum
force it could possibly apply
would be something on the
order of delta G divided
by the length that it's pulling.
Otherwise, you could make
a perpetual motion machine.
So this-- well,
maybe what we'll do
if we want to make
our math simpler,
we could say this is around 80.
It's of order there.
But the point is that this
is of order 10 picanewtons,
so it's kind of
picanewton scale.
All right.
So given this, it's interesting
to ask, how hard would you
have to pull?
So how big is a kinesin model
going to be, this protein?
AUDIENCE: About
eight nanometers.
JEFF GORE: Yeah, right,
about eight nanometers.
Of course, it's kind
of long, spindly things
like my skinny legs,
right, but let's
indeed going to be
around that scale,
whereas the cell is one micron
wide, multiple microns long, so
much, much larger.
We'll draw a little--
here's a kinesin in there.
It's even smaller than that.
Kinesin's small.
Now, the question is,
how much force would you
have to apply in order to
pull an E. coli at 30 microns
a second?
Force to pull E.
coli at the speed
that it's actually
observed to go-- now,
you're unlikely to be able to
do the calculation right here.
It's actually a
simple calculation.
We could do it in
a moment, but it's
useful to just kind of imagine
what scale might it be.
All right, this is a way of--
we can go up as high as we want.
You can continue it on and this
is all in units of picanewtons.
Once again, it's
useful to make guesses
about your intuition
on these things
just so you have some
notion of where we might be.
And of course, in this case,
nobody wants to guess anything,
because they feel--
all right, I'll
give you 10 seconds just
to make your best guess.
Somebody's forcing you to do it.
In this case, it's me.
No reason that you actually
should necessarily get this.
Pulling through water.
AUDIENCE: At 30 microns.
JEFF GORE: At 30
microns per second.
AUDIENCE: Could you
give us the viscosity
of water in picanewtons?
JEFF GORE: Yeah, it's
10 to the minus nine
in the units of picanewton
nanometer second something.
AUDIENCE: Great.
JEFF GORE: Right.
Now, I've given you enough time.
You should have just
been able-- now,
I'm going to be disappointed
if you don't get it right.
No.
Let's just see where we are.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
OK, so I'd say that we
have a bunch of-- I'd say
the mean is kind of a C-D-ish.
We got some A-B's.
All right, so I'd say it's
somewhere in the sense of,
yeah, maybe it's 100,000.
So maybe if you had 100 of these
kinesins pulling you along,
then you'd be able to go 30
microns a second, although you
have to be careful because
kinesin can't actually
go that fast.
But these are details, right?
No, there's a
reasonable question.
How hard would you have to pull.
Of course, if we want,
we could actually just
do the equations here, right?
The force, it's around 20.
In units of picanewton
nanometer seconds,
I told you that the eta is
around 10 to the minus 9.
All right.
And the radius, what
radius do you want to use?
AUDIENCE: A micron.
JEFF GORE: A micron.
So do we write a 1 here?
Do we write what?
10 to the 3 because
I already told you
that this was in units where
everything is picanewtons
nanometers seconds.
And velocity, this
is again per second.
So this is three times 10 to
the 4, because that's how many
nanometers per second.
And this gets us to around--
that's 10 to the seven.
We're going to have
to divide by 100,
so this is 60 divided by 100--
so less than a picanewton.
So this is really
pretty surprising.
And again, this is a reflection
of the wonders of low Reynolds
numbers kind of behavior.
So it's somewhere here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So since
there are many flagella,
is it telling us--
[INAUDIBLE] is it telling us
that they're very inefficient
compared to the [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Yeah, it's
a good question, right?
So I think there
are several ways.
And this is one
aspect maybe of what
we read about in the "Life
at Low Reynolds Numbers."
The comparison was to a
Datsun in Saudi Arabia.
Of course, I think that this
was written in the '70s where
that meant something.
But I think that a Datsun, I
guess, is a fuel efficient car?
Well, that was my
inference from that.
And Saudi Arabia has a
lot of oil, still true.
And the saying was that it might
only be 1% efficient or so,
right?
But if you don't have to
apply very much force there,
then maybe that's
not a disaster.
The swimming speed
is not actually
a super strong function
of the number of flagella
that are there, as far
as my understanding.
So I'm actually a little
bit-- there are cases
where you do get somewhat
higher speed with more flagella,
although I have to confess,
just from the geometry
of the multiple flagella I find
totally mystifying, because I
would've thought they
would get tangled up,
because each of them goes in
and they form a corkscrew.
I don't know.
It just doesn't seem
that it should work.
But it does, so I'm not going
to argue that it doesn't.
AUDIENCE: Probably it has to do
with the low Reynolds number.
So you imagine swimming,
sort of flying around.
JEFF GORE: Yeah, no,
my concern is not even
a matter of the low
Reynolds number or not.
It's just a matter of
they're each spinning
and then-- this is something
really I've never understood,
so I typically avoid
talking about it.
I don't know.
I just feel like
there's something wrong.
But in any case, you don't
need to pull very hard in order
to get even a micron-size
object to go rather fast.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Oh, I'm
not aware of it.
This thing can actually
go-- it's 10 microns long,
so this thing is huge, actually.
But I--
AUDIENCE: It's
probably just a repeat.
Or even if it is
a repeat, you can
[INAUDIBLE] I'd
just be surprised
if it wasn't, since
it seems like that.
JEFF GORE: Yeah,
so I don't know,
but I'm not even sure if
that would necessarily
address my concern, which
is it seems like they
have to go through each other.
But it's not true, so I don't
want to make the argument too
strongly.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: So I was just
thinking about this [INAUDIBLE]
Might it be possible that
they, if they are all sync up
their rotations, then it doesn't
matter how tangled they are?
JEFF GORE: Yeah, no,
even-- even if they're all
spinning at the exact
same rate, I still
feel that they
should get tangled,
but it's a feeling that
is apparently not true.
So I don't want to--
AUDIENCE: But if they're always
tumbling, maybe the time to--
JEFF GORE: No, no, no,
wait-- so it's not-- no,
the tumble is not due to
my supposed mechanism.
They're spinning at
something like 100 hertz.
The motors are spinning at
something like 100 hertz,
right?
So in principle, if they
were going to get tangled,
they would've gotten tangled.
AUDIENCE: Seems [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: That's
right, that's right.
I do want to just
come back and say
one thing about this
question of a rotary motor,
because it's a fascinating
question-- oh yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I just
had a quick question.
What was the units of eta again?
JEFF GORE: Oh,
this is the thing.
The units of eta, I
always just go back here
and I say, OK,
well, it's the units
of a force divided by unit of
an area-- or sorry, of a radius,
unit of a velocity, and then
I have to plug everything in.
And then, I have to find an
equation with a force other
than this equation, because if
you put this equation back in,
then you don't get anywhere.
These are useful.
So I always have to actually
figure it out fresh each time.
So it turns out that these
are indeed rotary motors.
And I think that this was
actually the first-- as far
as I'm aware, it's the first
example of a rotary motor
in biology that had
been demonstrated,
which is a fascinating idea
because in human engineering,
rotary motors are everywhere.
Yet somehow, if you
look at living things,
they don't seem to
have rotary motors.
Now, anybody want to suggest
why rotary motors might be rare
in biology, in life?
AUDIENCE: Rotary is just
that it rotates, right,
not in terms of a mechanism
[INAUDIBLE] because there's
also [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Well, I guess I'm
thinking of something that
can continuously rotate, right?
It's true that if you look
at-- we have ball socket joints
and I can rotate them a
little bit, but certainly,
I can't go-- there
are limits, right?
And this is a pretty
striking difference
between human engineering
and biological engineering.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you tried to
connect anything across this,
it would be more [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: That's right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
The problem is you
just can't have
anything connected across it.
Otherwise, you really
do get tangled, right?
Now, the question
then is, well, why
is it that it's possible
to do that here then?
AUDIENCE: Because we're
at such a small scale
that we're not thinking of
connecting anything else.
We're individual
molecules, anyway.
There's nothing that
can go through that.
JEFF GORE: Yeah,
it's interesting.
And this is how I think
about it that well,
at the molecular scale, you
just have some rotary something
and it doesn't
have to be attached
via, say, covalent
bonds or whatnot.
And you can then force
something to rotate.
Of course, it's a little
bit funny because this issue
about connecting across
this rotation, that
should be a problem for
human engineering, as well,
but somehow, we
do get around it.
I guess what I would
say is I don't have
any comments, except for this
was then quite a surprise when
it was discovered that this was
a rotor motor, just because we
had not seen any in other
macroscopic living things.
So then, it was quite
exciting to see it
in the case of the
flagellar motor.
And in your book,
you'll see that there's
a very nice kind of EM
reconstruction of this motor
and you can see how
it's hinged and it's
powered by proton gradients
that kind of cause this thing
to rotate.
It's really a beautiful,
amazing thing.
Does anybody know any other
examples of rotary motors?
That's right.
The other really famous one
is the F0F1 ATP synthase,
which is, again, something
that's across a membrane
and has, once again, a really
beautiful structure where
it has this circular thing
in the membrane that rotates,
responds to, again,
a proton gradient,
and then that drives
rotation of this other part
of the protein, F1.
And then, that makes ATP.
And that motor is amazing
also because it's reversible,
in that the cell can also
burn ATP and drive a proton
gradient.
And indeed, in some
single-molecule experiments,
they've even done
something where
they attached a little
magnetic particle onto this F1
and then rotated themselves.
And they showed that they
could actually make ATP.
The efficiency was maybe not
great, something like that,
because they're rotating
a macroscopic magnet
and then they're
making ATPs there.
But it's a pretty
remarkable aspect
of these molecular motors.
Now in this class,
we're not going
to say anything more
about molecular motors,
but I just wanted to mention
a few things about them
because they're really
fun, beautiful things
and there are other
classes that are
at MIT that may give you an
opportunity to think about them
some more.
Any question about
where we are now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: The common motor?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Oh.
Well, I'd say that the
other class of motors
that are seen a
lot in the context
of these molecular
motors are motors that
travel along linear tracks.
So there's kinesin that
walks along microtubules.
There are various myosins
that walk on actin.
And then, of course,
DNA and RNA polymerase,
we don't normally
think of them as motors
but indeed, they
take an energy fuel
and then they have to
walk along the template
as they make either
the DNA or the RNA.
So I'd say there are many, many
examples of molecular motors
that convert chemical
energy into mechanical force
and motion, particularly
along one-dimensional tracks.
So those, I think, are the
most well-studied examples.
Now, one way to study
this run and tumble motion
is, of course, to
actually apply a gradient
and then watch the
cells as they swim it.
And that has been done.
A lot's been learned
from that kind of assay,
but it turns out that there
are two other assays that maybe
allowed for more
controlled analysis
of this chemotaxis
kind of response.
So let's just say-- so
studying chemotaxis.
The most obvious thing
is to apply a gradient
and then watch.
And indeed, the
classic assays where
you add a little pipette with
an attractant or a repellent
and watch the bacteria
swim toward or away,
that demonstrates there
is indeed chemotaxis.
But it's a little bit
difficult to quantify
that process in many cases.
What are the assays that maybe
you've read about recently?
In [? Yuri's ?] book, how is
it that they actually analyzed
this perfect adaptation?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you can bind the
flagella on the slide and then
[INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: So one thing
that you can do is you can--
I may put it here.
All right.
So you can kind of attach
the cell to a slide.
And typically attach it
to the slide by what?
This isn't it.
And does it matter where you
attach the cell to the slide?
AUDIENCE: By the flagella.
JEFF GORE: Yeah,
so you typically
have attach it via this
hook that's at the end,
so by some part of the
flagella-- to the slide
by the flagella, we'll say.
Flagellum?
Flagella-- whatever.
And the nice thing there is that
as the cell is doing its thing
and it's spinning either
clockwise or counterclockwise,
you can directly visualize
that because the whole cell is
moving.
And the cell is both the
thing that is doing the work
and processing the
signals and everything,
but it's also your
marker for what the state
of this little hook is, right?
This is a wonderfully
quantitative assay where you
can get high time resolution.
It's easy to do
the image analysis.
And then, how do you typically
get this cell to change its,
for example, tumbling frequency?
AUDIENCE: Put an attractant.
JEFF GORE: Right, so you
can add an attractant.
And indeed, I just wanted to
separate this a little bit,
because you can-- even
without doing this--
this is kind of the next
order step-- you can just
add an attractant and
mix, because you don't
want the spatial patterns.
But a nice thing here,
this is a gradient in space
and then you can watch
the bacteria swim.
But you can also have
the gradient in time.
And the cells can't
tell the difference.
The nice thing here is
that you can then just
add the attractant,
mix, and then
you just watch all the
cells as they're going.
You don't need to try to
follow them or whatnot,
but you can just look to see how
the tumbling frequency changes
over time.
And of course, you would
typically use this trick
together with this in order to
study perfect adaptation and so
forth.
If you collect this sort of
data and you plot the tumbling
frequency as a function of
time, what you might see
is that it starts out
at one per second.
Now, if at this time,
I add an attractant,
does the tumbling
frequency go up or down?
And we're going to
do a verbal answer.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Down.
JEFF GORE: Down.
And that makes sense
because the cells
think that they're moving
up an attractant gradient.
So over a very short time scale,
tumbling frequency goes down.
But then, over a time
scale of minutes--
it might be 5, 10 minutes--
that tumbling frequency
goes back to where it started.
I just want to--
this varies, but this
could be order of 10 minutes.
AUDIENCE: Why is it so long?
JEFF GORE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 10 minutes
is a very long time.
JEFF GORE: Yeah, it's
a long time scale.
And here's a question.
Is it because this
is the time that it
takes to make new protein?
New protein
synthesis, we'll say.
AUDIENCE: You're asking
if that's the time
or if that's the
reason why is it long?
JEFF GORE: I'm saying is this
the explanation for why this
is 10 minutes,
because the cell has
to go make new protein
in order to do this?
So the cell is presumably going
to be making some new proteins,
but is this what
you would really
describe as being the causative
agent of this thing taking 10,
20 minutes?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
So I'd say most people are
agreeing that actually,
yes, it is.
The answer is no.
This is not.
It may be the case that the
cell is making new protein,
but this is not what's
setting the time scale there.
Is--
AUDIENCE: More [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Right.
You agreed that that was the
answer, but you didn't-- well,
so I would say there are several
ways you can think about this,
but we're going to go through
the model that is supported
by, I think, a fair amount
of experimental evidence.
But the key feature there
is that in this model,
it works even if all the
protein concentrations are
constant over time.
So everything that's
happening in this network
is happening as a
result of changes
of the states of the protein.
So proteins are either getting
methylated or phosphorylated
and these-- right.
But then, of course,
it's the question of,
why is it 10 minutes instead
of 10 seconds or a minute?
AUDIENCE: You need a
[INAUDIBLE] in there
that's on the order of minutes,
like 100 minutes, which
is very slow.
Is there--
JEFF GORE: Yeah, well,
their one question is, this
is what is called
the adaptation time.
Now, is this a robust
feature in this model
or in the cells,
for that matter?
We'll just add
verbal, yes or no.
Ready?
Three, two, one,
AUDIENCE: No.
JEFF GORE: No.
Now, and what that
means is that indeed,
different kind of
versions of this network
will have different times.
And there is data looking
at variation in this
between different cells.
And I guess I don't have
a clear feeling for what
would be optimal, in the sense
of allowing optimal climbing up
of an attractant gradient.
This thing has to be much
longer than the typical times
for a tumble.
Otherwise, it's
not even-- well, we
wouldn't have been able
to measure it, I guess.
But I agree that it could
have been one minute
and I wouldn't
have batted an eye,
in the sense that I don't
have any feeling for why
it had to have been
this or something else.
But somebody who
actually studies this
might be able to
give a better answer.
All right.
AUDIENCE: But I guess--
sorry, just one last thing.
My question is not
why it's 10 minutes.
It's not an
evolutionary question,
like why is it useful, right?
It's just somehow, [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Yeah I
think that there
are different ways
of looking at this
and then depending on
how you look at it,
you either feel
surprised or not.
So it's a little--
now on the other hand,
if you had added
a repellent, then
the tumbling frequency
would actually go up
and then come back down.
But the key, key
thing in this system
that we want to focus
our attention on
is the fact that it comes
back to where it started.
So it's the fact that I can
draw this dashed line that
is this perfect adaptation.
And so what we want
to do is understand
where this phenomenon
of perfect adaptation
comes from and maybe why
it is robust to changes
in, for example, the
concentrations of some
of these proteins.
Now, let's just
make sure that we're
all on the same page in
terms of what was known
about this chemotaxis network.
And I think it's worth
mentioning, perhaps, here
that the whole series of
studies of bacterial chemotaxis
going back to Howard
Berg and company
and then later, the
studies that in robustness
that Uri Alon and Stan
Leibler and Naama Barkai did.
I think they represent really
just a wonderfully beautiful
exploration at the interface
between physics and biology.
I think you could teach
an entire course just
on bacterial chemotaxis and
you could hit pretty much
all the major themes in
biophysics over the last 40
years.
It's really amazing to me.
I myself have not done
any work in the field,
but from afar, I've really
just admired the beauty
of all these studies.
And because you go back
to Howard Berg and Purcell
and they're thinking about
how simple physics can inform
the challenges that
bacteria are facing
and how cells are actually
able to do a biased random walk
and get anywhere, limits on
sensing both concentrations
and gradients-- and
then later, the studies
that they're this
topic of robustness,
it's really a
wonderful example where
Naama Barkai, when she was
a postdoc at Stan Leibler,
they had published a Nature
paper in maybe '97 basically
saying, this idea of robustness
is really important in biology
and in order to have a robust
response of perfect adaptation,
a model has to have
these features.
So there's no experiments
there, but their model
was guided by
previous observations
that people had made.
And then, two years
later, Uri, when
he was a postdoc in
Stan's lab again,
did kind of the
experimental confirmation
of the model, where
he went in and he
controlled the
concentration of chi R
and showed that thee key
predictions of the model, i.e.
the perfect adaptation, would
be robust to the concentration
but that the tumbling frequency
and the adaptation time, they
would not be robust to
chi R concentrations.
They would move
in a way predicted
by the model and all that.
It's really amazing that it
all kind of holds together,
because in many cases, we do
the modeling kind of post facto,
right?
And then, it's kind of
explaining our results.
But the case where a
model is really useful
is when it makes new
predictions that get you
to go make new measurements.
And this is a
situation where there
are an infinite number of
experiments that you could do,
but only some of them
will actually provide you
a deep insight into
the mechanisms that
are going on in the system.
And I think this was a real
case where the models made
some really clear predictions
and that allowed, in this case,
Uri to go and make the strains
that allowed him to test
the predictions of the model.
And I think it's really amazing
that it all kind of works.
All right.
Now, all of the letters
that you see up there,
they're not actually-- well,
first of all, the letters
are somehow real.
This is the real names
of the protein components
in the chemotaxis
network in E. coli
and largely in other organisms.
But in each case, there's a
chi that comes in front, right?
So R corresponds to
chi R, for example.
And then, there's
chi B, chi W, chi A.
And these were all identified
by genetics, so then
by researchers looking
for mutants that
were defective in chemotaxis.
I don't know what
happened to C, D, E, F, G,
because it does seem like we got
the first part of the alphabet
and the last part
of the alphabet.
I don't know.
All right.
Now, the basic
idea in the system
is that you have chi W/A that
we often here will refer to as X
just for simplicity.
Now, these are proteins
in the membrane,
so they have a binding
kind of pocket outside
that will allow binding of
attractants or repellents.
There might be say,
five different kinds
of these receptor
complexes that can sense,
that bind at different rates,
different kinds of attractants,
repellents, and then the
signal is somehow integrated.
Now, this could be either an
attractant or a repellant.
The distinction
between these two
is that we get different
levels of methylation
onto chi W. Now in
this lecture, we're
only going to be talking
about the methylated state
versus the unmethylated.
But in reality, depending on
the receptor complex they have,
they might have four or five
different methylation sites.
And this ability to switch
between different methylation
states is really at the
heart of the phenomenon
of robust perfect adaptation.
The base feature in it, though,
is that chi A can phosphorylate
chi Y and chi Y will then
go and yield the output,
which is in this case,
increased tumbling frequency.
But there are lots of
other bells and whistles
that you can see on here, right?
So of course, it's not just
that this phosphorylated
chi Y just kind of
comes off on its own,
but rather it's
actually done by chi Z.
So there's a
constant cycling here
and again, there's a
where the methyl groups are
taken off and then put back on.
So if you look at
this, you really
do feel that it's
rather wasteful,
because there's a huge number
of these futile cycles going on.
Chi Y is always kind of
being phosphorylated and then
dephosphorylated and this is all
going to be costly to the cell.
So you can imagine
then the only reason
it's there is because it's
doing something useful.
Now, there was a
comment in the chapter
about what is the rate
limiting step in all this.
And can somebody
remember what it was?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it methylation?
JEFF GORE: So methylation,
there is a sense
that that is actually
the longest time scale,
but I guess because
the methylation
is what results in
this thing coming
in the perfect adaptation
over this 10 minutes.
I guess what I meant-- so yeah,
that is the longest time scale.
But I guess what I was
thinking about in rate limiting
is the sense of when
the cell finds itself
in a new environment,
it changes its state
over a much shorter time scale.
So this thing I drew is
almost vertical, right?
So this question is, if
the cell finds itself
in a new environment suddenly
and then it just really
wants to tumble-- so you find
yourself in a crappy bar,
how long does it take
for you to get out?
Now, what's going to
be rate limiting there?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Phospho--
phosphorylation.
JEFF GORE:
Phosphorylation, yeah,
although it turns out that's
not the rate limiting step.
And this actually comes back
a little bit to something
that we talked about in
the first part of the class
that in these
transcription networks,
the characteristic
timescale is what?
AUDIENCE: G.
JEFF GORE: Right.
So the characteristic timescale
in the case of transcription
networks is the time
it takes for you
to change concentrations of
proteins, which is kind of cell
generation time or if you
have active degradation,
you might be able to make it
faster, whereas all of this
is happening rather
quickly, say,
maybe 1/10 tenth of a second.
And a lot of these kinds of
processes, binding, unbinding,
and actually even
the interactions
between the proteins
can take place
even maybe faster than that.
So the actual rate limiting step
for when the cell finds itself
in a bad environment
for it to start tumbling
is actually due to diffusion.
And that's diffusion of what?
AUDIENCE: Y protein.
JEFF GORE: Yeah, diffusion of
the phosphorylated Y, right?
And that's because we
have the cells here.
They find themselves
in the bad environment.
They rapidly bind the
repellent or they quickly
phosphorylate chi
Y. But then, Y is
going to be formed
at one of the poles,
because actually, there's
actually clustering
of these receptors at
the poles of a cell
and incidentally, we're not
going to talk about that here,
but I think there's strong
experimental and theoretical
evidence that this actually
increases the sensitivity.
And indeed, people have used
simple Ising type models
to try to understand how the
coupling between the binding
of repellents on what's
essentially almost
like a crystalline
array of receptors
can allow the array
to better than you
build it to as an individual.
We're not going to get into
that here, but in any case,
there's receptors
at the poles-- I
don't know if it's
both poles or one pole,
but one of the
poles of the other--
and that's where chi
Y is phosphorylated.
But then, you can see that
these flagella are distributed
all around the cell.
So you have to diffuse
from say, the pole
to the site of
the flagella motor
in order to cause it to go
clockwise and then cause
a tumble.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So do you
need only one motor?
JEFF GORE: Yeah, so
you actually only
need one motor to
get the tumbling.
And so then, you may not
have to diffuse all the way
to the other end, but-- and of
course, diffusion is random.
And we all know that 0.1
seconds is around the time
that it takes for a
protein-sized object
to diffuse across the
volume of a bacterial cell.
We did that calculation
a couple weeks ago.
So 0.1 seconds is indeed--
so the rate limiting step
is indeed this step
right here, which
is diffusion of chi Y, the
phosphorylated version of it.
All right.
Now, we may not get too
much into the models
here, because you
did read about them.
But I will just
kind of sketch out
sort of what you might call
the fine-tuned model and then
the key assumption that
goes into this robust model.
Now, what both models
assume and indeed
what was known
from previous work
was that chi R is
present at small number.
So chi R, there might be around
100 proteins in the cell.
And what does this mean
about the activity of chi R?
What is the other word for it?
It doesn't actually
have to quite mean it,
but what is it that-- how--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: [? High ?] saturation.
JEFF GORE: So yeah,
something is high.
And what is typically assumed is
that chi R acts at saturation,
chi R. But what do we mean by
"saturation" in these models?
AUDIENCE: Maximum.
JEFF GORE: Right.
Does it mean that
if we add more chi
R than the rate of methylation,
it doesn't increase?
And I should have put a
little methyl group here.
There are multiple
things you might
mean by "acts at saturation."
And in the models that
you read about last night,
is what it means that if we
increase the number of chi R
that it doesn't change
the rate of methylation?
Yes or no?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: No.
JEFF GORE: No.
And what they mean is something
rather different, which
is that if we plot or if
we calculate the change
in the concentration
of the methylated X--
now, we're calling this
whole thing Xm, methylated X,
and this is just X.
The assumption is
that we have X is
being methylated
at a rate that is-- there's
no Michaelis-Menten term.
If we were to write this
as it not being saturated,
what is it acting on?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Yeah, it's
not the methylated x.
So indeed, if we
were to write this,
we're assuming that this is
at saturation, as they say.
But any time that you
see something like this,
you have to ask,
well, what would
be the alternative, right?
And the alternative
would be to include
a term that looks kind of like
just X over some K plus X,
because R is acting
on the unmethylated X.
We're not including that.
What that means is that we're
assuming that this thing is
saturated, that the
concentration of X to be acted
on is significantly larger than
the Michaelis constant there.
And of course, this is
related to the amount of R,
because as we get
more and more R,
then eventually, we'll
remove some of this X
and then we'll get into
the non-saturated regime.
So these two statements
are related, but not
the same thing.
Now, there's also some rate that
the phosphorylated version of B
removes the methyl groups
and that's indeed just going
to be this Michaelis constant.
And this is going to be
for the fine-tuned model.
The robust model
looks very similar,
but this is the simplest kind
of manifestation of this model.
Now, once we're
writing this down,
it's useful to make
sure that we can
keep track of what's
actually happening
over the course of
perfect adaptation.
So now, let's imagine first
that an attractant arrives.
That's going to change
the activity of X.
And when we say
"activity," what we mean
is the rate that's it's going
to phosphorylate both B and Y.
So let's just make sure
that we know this direction.
So we add an attractant.
We'll say "add."
What does this do?
Does it make activity
go up or down?
I'll give you 15
seconds to make sure
that you kind of understand
the workings of this network.
This is activity of X,
this complex X. All right.
Do you need more time?
All right.
Let's see where we are.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
So we got a majority
of the group
is saying that it
should go down.
Well, let's just
follow the logic.
So we imagine an
attractant binding.
If the activity goes
down, that means
that we get less of
the phosphorylated chi
Y. That means we get less
propensity to tumbling,
which means that we
keep on going further.
All right, that
sounds reasonable.
Any questions about that logic?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Right.
So we haven't said
anything yet about BM.
That's what going
to happen next.
And that's actually
the slow time scale.
So what we had in
here is that we
were kind of at this
steady-state tumbling
frequency of one per second.
We add an attractant.
The tumbling frequency goes down
because of what we just said.
But now, there's going to
be this longer time scale
process whereby we
get recovery, where
we come back to this
steady-state tumbling
frequency.
And that's going to
involve action on chi B.
All right.
So what happens is that
the attractant causes less
of the phosphorylated
chi Y. But it's also
going to cause less of the
phosphorylated chi B. Now, that
means that we're going
to-- and remember,
the phosphorylated
chi B is what's
removing the methyl groups.
So if we have less
flux going to the left,
but we have the
same-- at that moment,
we don't have any change in
the flux going to the right.
So chi R is still acting on the
same unmethylated X's that it
was operating on before.
So it's the same flux to the
right, less flux to the left.
So there's a net accumulation of
the methylated receptor, which
we are calling X. So the
key thing here is that--
and it's this
methylated receptor that
has more activity.
In this model, this
unmethylated version actually
doesn't have any activity.
So then, if we get more of the
methylated X, then over time,
we get a buildup
of the methylated X
and that causes the
activity to come back up.
Now, of course,
there's a question
of-- I just said that
it comes back up,
but I didn't say
that it comes back up
exactly to its original
tumbling frequency.
I didn't say that it necessarily
displays perfect adaptation.
And that's because
in this model,
the perfect adaptation
arises as a result of what
we call fine-tuning,
because it only
happens if all of the
parameters are just so.
In Uri's book, he describes
a typical condition
where that would be the case.
And the problem is
that you can always
fine-tune for some
concentrations of everything,
chi R or chi this, chi that.
But then if the
concentrations change,
then you're no longer
fine-tuned correctly.
You were fine-tuned
for a different world
and now you're not-- and
that's the definition of being
fine-tuned is that
if things change,
you're no longer fine-tuned.
You're just finely
off-tune, right?
So this is the problem
with the fine-tuned model
is that you can get
it right for a given--
for given concentrations
of everything,
you can always
find what numbers.
This is VB and
then there's going
to be-- you can talk about
the activities of XM given
the previous attractant
concentration and so on and so
forth, but it's not
going to be fine-tuned
if you change
anything else, like
if you change concentration
of R, for example.
And I'm happy to
go through the math
and so forth maybe after
class if anybody's curious,
but it's really
precisely what Uri did,
so maybe I won't
get into it now.
But the question
then is, well, how
is it that you might
change this model in order
to make it robust?
And the change is somehow
surprisingly simple,
which is that what you want
is chi B, instead of just
acting on any old
methylated X, you
want it to act only on
the methylated X that
is in sort of in what we
would call this active state,
where it's actually
able to catalyze
either of those reactions.
So the notion is that if you
have this methylated X, then
it's kind of over a
very fast time scale.
It's switching between what
we call an "active" state
and some inactive one.
And it's really only
in the active versions
that chi B is able to act on
and remove the methyl group.
And this is on the one
hand a clever thing
that allows you to implement
this integral feedback.
On the other hand, it's a little
bit of like pulling a bunny out
of a hat, because you feel
like, well, these things may
be happening over
microsecond time scales.
It's hard to know exactly--
how would you actually
experimentally confirm this
is precisely what's going on?
And I think that here, it's a
little bit subtle because you
could maybe show that indeed
the rate of this demethylation
is proportional to
the activity here,
but you don't
necessarily have access
to all of the molecular
dynamics that are taking place
over microsecond time scales.
So I think that you can do
measurements that give you
confidence that this is
maybe what's going on,
but you can't quite
100% nail it because
of the nature of these
molecular fluctuations.
So the idea there
is that if we say
that there's this
rapid shuttling
between the so-called
"active" and "inactive"
methylated guys-- so this
is indicating that it's
what we call "active," able
to catalyze this and this--
then this ends up
being equivalent
to integral feedback,
where you'll always
get perfect adaptation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you
put [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: So the idea is that
we imagine that we're this
receptor X. It's chi W, chi A.
Now whether it's-- let's say
it's bound to something.
It still bound to an
attractant, right?
The way that the attractant
influences its activity--
and it has to influence
its activity if it's
going to do anything--
what we assume
is the way that it's doing
it is that it's changing
the sort of fraction
of time that I'm
in some active conformation
where I can actually do work,
versus the inactive conformation
where I'm taking a break.
So when you get the
attractant and you
spend more of your time in
this active conformation
where you're, in this case,
phosphorylating proteins,
and that's sort of the
mechanism through which
an attractant or a
repellent or whatnot
actually transmits its signal.
And indeed, it has
to do something.
Nothing that we're
discussing would work at all
if we don't allow the signal
to be transmitted somehow
through this receptor.
So there is this sense
that this activity
has to be a function of
the things out there.
And the assumption that goes
into the perfect adaptation
is really that the
rate of demethylation
is proportional to that
kind of active fraction.
And then, you can argue about
how discrete these entities
have to be in order for the
mechanism to work and so forth,
but certainly, there
has to be some way
that binding to an attractant
leads to what we decided
was less activity.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question.
So what's the relationship
between activity
and methylation?
Was it [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: So the idea is that
we're typically maybe assuming
that the unmethylated
guy has no activity,
so it doesn't do any of
this phosphorylation,
whereas the methylated
guy has some activity.
And you can characterize
it by some rate of activity
or some fraction
of the time that it
is in this active state
that is doing something.
Now, the question--
and indeed this
ends up-- well, you can see
here that in this model,
because you're directly
acting on the active XM, then
the steady-state
activity you can
get from just setting this equal
to zero and it's some number.
But then, the
question is, how long
does it take to come back
to that steady state?
And that's where
we get differences
as a function of
concentration of chi R,
because what's
happening always is
that we have some kind
of cycle here where
chi B is removing
the methyl groups,
groups chi R is
adding them back.
So you can imagine that
if you have more chi
R than a steady state, you get
more-- when you're moving right
by a steady state,
you have to have
the same moving to the left,
because at steady state,
it's equal.
So the more chi R you
have, the faster this thing
is going around.
And that means that the
more chi R that you have,
the more rapidly that you'll
get this perfect adaptation.
So the experiment that Uri
did that I think is very nice
is he directly modulated
the amount of chi R
and he looked at
this adaptation time.
And he found this
kind of came down,
whereas if you look at
the steady-state tumbling
frequency, this came
up, whereas the degree
of perfect adaptation,
say the ratio or the error
in this thing,
perfect adaptation
was always kind of correct, in
the sense it always came back
to its original value.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
You say the [INAUDIBLE]
it only phosphorylates
chi B when an
attractant [INAUDIBLE]
Y [INAUDIBLE] attractant.
JEFF GORE: No.
So the attractant
or repellent can
be combined to
either the methylated
or the non-methylated, right?
AUDIENCE: But [INAUDIBLE]
only [INAUDIBLE]
phosphorylation of
chi B when [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: No.
So you're talking
about-- oh, OK.
So it's really that the
methylated state can
phosphorylate either
chi B or chi Y,
but this is regardless whether
an attractant is bound or not.
The attractant will influence
the rate or the activity
that this happens.
And given this model, you can
see that you have more chi R,
then at steady state, you're
going to have more activity.
More activity corresponds
to more phosphorylated chi
y and more tumbling,
so an increase
in the tumbling frequency.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I guess
it's not clear to me
where the ligand concentration
actually come in.
JEFF GORE: Where
which concentration?
AUDIENCE: The ligand
concentration.
JEFF GORE: Oh, OK, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because
that's what [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Yeah, right.
Yeah, so the idea here
is that if we start out
without any attractant--
so first of all,
so let's imagine
we're at steady state.
There's no attractant
or little attractant
now, where of course, the
fluxes to the left and the right
are the same.
So there's some
methylated, some not.
AUDIENCE: No, but I agree the
mechanics of just in the actual
to write an equation
for the ligands
to come in like [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF GORE: Right.
So the idea is that when
you bind an attractant,
that's going to change the
activity of the methylated.
So it's going to
change, for example,
the fraction that are active.
AUDIENCE: And
decreases the activity.
JEFF GORE: And it decreases
the activity, right.
AUDIENCE: And some
sort of signal--
JEFF GORE: Yeah,
there's some-- right.
And of course, we haven't
specified what that function,
but the idea is that it leads
to a rapid decrease in activity,
which corresponds to a rapid
decrease in this fraction that
are active XM star.
Does that make sense?
So the last thing I wanted
to do is say something
about what this means
for individuality.
In particular, let's
imagine that we
have a clonal
population of bacteria.
And the question
is, in what ways
will they be similar
or different?
So now, we can just
imagine an experiment
where I take a population
of cells with exactly
the same genetic code and I
go and I measure, for example,
the tumbling frequency
across this population.
So we can talk about-- we
measure f1, f2, f3, fn--
so these are the tumbling
frequencies across n cells.
This is n we'll say
genetically identical cells.
The question is, will we get
the same tumbling frequency
or should these
things be the same?
And if not, why not?
So let's just do our
little votes, all right?
We have should they be the same
or should they be different.
All right.
Do you understand the question?
Let's vote.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
Well, OK, so at least
the majority of people
are saying they
should be different.
And why might that be, somebody?
AUDIENCE: We might
have [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Right.
For example, we
might have variation
in the concentration
of chi R. Now,
this variation is sort
of a natural result
of just fluctuating
this or that, right?
But it's a little bit similar
to the experiment Uri did,
where he actually in
this case has actually
put chi R under the control of
an inducible promoter, where
he could just add IPDG
and drive expression
and then just measure
the mean of these things
across the population.
But even if you try to have
everything be the same,
you'll have some
variation, which
we found for small numbers
of proteins could be large.
So that variation
will transmit itself
into variations in both
the adaptation time
and the tumbling frequency.
And this is indeed was
observed as early as 1976.
So there's a paper
in Nature in 1976
by Jim Spudich and Dan Koshland.
So Spudich went on
to study a number
of these molecular motors.
In particular, he studied
many of these myosins.
But he wrote this classic paper
in '76 called "Non-genetic
individuality, chance
in the single cell."
What he did is they looked at
many different individual cells
using a few of those techniques
that I told you about.
And what they found is
that some of the cells
seemed to be what they
called kind of "twitchy"
and some of them seemed
to be more relaxed.
So the twitchy cells are the
guys that had a larger tumbling
frequency.
So they wouldn't swim
as far as the others.
So they'd swim just
a little bit and then
they'd change their mind, swim
a little bit, change their mind,
whereas other cells had
much longer kind of runs,
even though they're all
nominally identical.
Now, can somebody
say the time scale
over which we would expect
that personality to persist?
AUDIENCE: Cell generation time.
JEFF GORE: Yeah,
cell generation time.
And why is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Yeah, right.
So if this is chi R, over time,
it's going to do something.
And so the typical
autocorrelation time
should be kind of the
cell generation time.
So what we call the typical time
should be rather generational.
So indeed, this is
the same as humans.
We have a well-defined
personality
and then we pass on some of
our personality to our kids.
The typical time
scale is a generation.
So I'm teaching you guys super
useful things in this class.
I don't want anybody
saying anything else.
But I think that this
is a neat example of how
different cells can have
what you might describe
as being somehow
different personalities,
but it arises for a
very particular reason
because this information
is being transmitted
through this network.
Now, despite the
fact that they all
have different chi
R concentrations--
so they might have different
tumbling frequencies
and so forth, but
they should all
be able to display
this phenomenon
of perfect adaptation.
So what we then see is
that from the experiments
and from some simple
models, you can
get insight into how it
is that this phenomenon
of perfect adaptation
might be robust to changes
in the concentrations of
different things, particularly
chi R in this case.
And chi R is the
dominant source of error
because it's present
in such small numbers.
Now, in the last
two minutes or so,
I just want to remind everybody
about the other context
in which we studied
robustness, because it's
a much simpler
example and it helps
to clarify what we mean by it.
Does anybody remember
the other context
that we have talked
about robustness?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF GORE: Negative
autoregulation someone
said, maybe?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JEFF GORE: OK, good, all right.
So if we have some
protein that is negatively
autoregulating itself,
then this adds robustness.
And this is because
we can say, all right,
this is the degradation term,
alpha x, the production term.
And the limit of being perfect,
sharp, negative autoregulation
looks like this.
So this is the
production/degradation.
And here, this might be beta.
This is a k.
Then, what we can
talk about is how
the steady-state concentration
of x here is going to be k.
And this thing is robust to
variations in some things,
but not other things.
For example, it's robust
to changes in alpha.
That changes the slope.
It's robust to changes in
beta, because that just
brings it up and down, but it's
not robust to changes in k.
So I think that any time
that if you are confused
about robustness, in particular
thinking about robustness
in the context of
chemotaxis gets
you confused because of perfect
adaptation being confusing,
I think it's always good
to come back and think
about this because this is the
most clear case where you can
talk about-- this
is the robustness
of the steady-state
concentration
of some protein against
variations in alpha and beta,
but not against k.
So it reminds you that it's
not that this level of x
is robust against
everything, but it's
robust against some things.
And you can make sense
of which things it
should be robust against,
which things not.
So with that, I think
we're going to quit.
I just want to remind
everybody that none
of the work that we're
talking about here
in the context of chemotaxis
and the genetic network
will appear on the
exam, but we may
have a problem on low
Reynolds number flow,
maybe something Stokes drag.
Diffusion might
make an appearance.
Good luck on the exam.
I'll see you guys on Tuesday.